étrangers
[Music] les
gens avec des capacités spéciales vous pouvez être
ce que vous voulez être je ne peux pas rester assis ici
et vous regarder courir sur place et aller après
je suis plus rapide que vous n'avez jamais essayé
vous êtes un homme brillant le meilleur absolu
du  mieux
vaut faire de votre propre avenir votre propre avenir [Applaudissements] c'est bon maintenant
vous ne pouvez pas tourner le dos au monde
pour toujours au-dessus ou au-dessous de milliers d'
années depuis que notre peuple a parlé le premier
né de la reine bien-aimée de la terre J'ai besoin de
guerriers le
temps est venu  prendre le privé de ta mère
c'est une mauvaise idée
Bobby McDowell dans son armée
le monde entier pleure
un symbole espérons que tu n'es pas trop
tard c'est comme s'ils avaient peur de voler
certains il est temps que je fasse une promesse
à ce sujet nous '  Je le ferai ensemble,
vous les aiderez à
accomplir des merveilles
[Musique]
Ils voulaient que je revienne pour une raison,
je dois découvrir pourquoi
[Musique]